yay hello and welcome to another tea
session let's play some games
um now I'm wrong here right to go here
really started with one of the five plus
three and I'm getting a game right away
so that's good having black here against
Braidwood so um you know kind of the
default for me
and then got some choice can play the
rosin or the BOGO
mm-hmm yeah you can also do this which
is a bit of an offbeat line which is not
all that bad it's very rarely played
that's not too bad
okay I'm going to check and it has a
distinct Bogle flavor and now of course
my TBD - yeah okay I'm going to give up
this Bishop on d2
just what happens in dis opening so five
and yeah maybe he's going to
yeah if he castles I can take on d2 it's
a bit of
could be a little bit of an annoyance at
this moment huh yeah what I was thinking
is if I take on d2 now am I not just
winning a pawn I mean it might be that
it is not entirely clear but okay I'm
going to do it him so if he takes with
anything else but the night I'm playing
E for and I'm winning a piece there's a
fork on e4
with this and Knight takes I can take D
form sometimes white gets compensation
for this kind of pawn rabbits it's it's
really possible but yeah now that I'm in
this position after castles I'm more or
less forced to
to call his bluff so the same okay now
let's take this he's got a check
Mookie one check and
the issue is Bishop 6 or 96
mm damn tough call
yeah I think I'm going
the night it's unstable on before anyway
and c5 might be a good spot after have
castled the point here is that white has
compensation for the pawn simply because
of the dark squared bishop that he still
has um an idea could be to just play
something like b3 or before and put it
on the long diagonal young so this is
exactly what I was talking about and
this gives white some compensation I'm
not sure how much it is it's definitely
something but on the other hand yeah if
you can't win a central pawn hmm it's
something that is usually there should
usually be done okay now should only be
two here I wanted to play this move
Bishop to h5 and then Bishop g6 trying
to get rid of one of his bishops yes the
bishop on b1 is also clogging up his
queen side but it's still useful to
trade yam to e6 or to d7
I guess two is six and desperation
this is covering the DeForest square so
after Bishop g6 there's no 94 coming
okay let's not move that head on the
radar at all but rookie idea looks good
nothing wrong about dead mills
you
okay yeah Bishop g6 I wanted to do this
anyway so white has some compensation
but the
the one point with this kind of
compensation is that I don't have a
structural problem my pawn structure is
very sound and he has to be I think
quite accurate in keeping something
going because if he does not really gain
anything yeah kunkuma concrete then it
kind of evaporates yeah the this
initiative um still it's a very strong
Bishop if I play rook a to win this
position mean it's that good
I'm not quite sure it could be him
that it doesn't lead to all that much
okay I can take b2 here is this a move
that I should consider
yeah why not is there something wrong
about it like Bishop h7 f7 no I don't
see it and if I take it here Bishop f5 I
can even take B form
before is hanging
if anything bishop f7 rook takes is sick
something miraculous but I don't think
this should work
No
[Music]
yeah okay that's an interesting move
so at least he saves the pawn is there
something no nothing
can't do anything extraordinary here so
I just moved the rock away so Quincy 3
was a good move here a white
yes getting gaining some space but I
think I'm going d5
and the nc6 next one of them important
factors in such a position here that I
have is that the knight on f6 is
extremely as you call it stable it's a
very stable piece that cannot easily be
attacked by anything and this is an
important point it's kit covers t5 it
covers h7 and it's difficult to see how
white is making any headway here as long
as the knight is one f6
it kind of yeah ties everything together
so it's
in a bit of tea right
yeah be fine
I play rugby 6 and then the Queen has no
square to go to that still covers b5
you know that looks very good actually
I mean not not like a winning position
but I don't see him much
threat coming from wilds position him
I also expected 95 instead of the Queen
move a km
maybe it doesn't even work gambit
trying to take on c6 with the night
would be more dangerous okay so now how
is handling this if he just retreats
let's say Quincy 3 going to play Queen
d6 really pay attention to the knight on
f6 this is important the bishop on b2
doesn't exist anymore and that means
there is no way that he can pressurize
this piece okay now what's going on here
Bishop takes is 6
yeah the question yeah can I take before
him I surely can I can also play would
be six
yeah Brooke before Bishop e6 rookie six
rupees six rupees six kind of a fancy
chest but doesn't doesn't really work
for more than one reason so how to how
to do this
the most normal was this one so let's do
this
don't not trying to be particularly
fancy
maybe queen aage year for
for a temple basically on the Queen I
expect the Queen to to move again
think he wants to trade the Queens
so he allows a Queen's radium this on a
form
so let's put more pressure on before
the rukon b6 is nice the guarding ecigs
yeah now do we want to
[Music]
think do I want to get rid of this it's
an interesting question
yeah Mike I think I can also just
position a little bit more
if aids something like that
we're taken before he's going to get a
six at the end not the end of the world
but I think I could I can do better
you
new okay now that is true reasonable
move
I cannot play Roo could be seven now as
he takes takes it six at the end but
maybe I should do this actually
yeah it's not ideal but
I don't don't see much don't seem much
else and at the end of the day I will
still have to connected passes
after Brook takes rook takes Bishop e6
pawn takes rook e6 I take before again
that's not what I wanted but should
still be pretty strong
maybe rook c6 here hmm yeah now that I
see them and all that I see this it's
kind of awkward
because I more or less have to play Ruby
7
oh I don't know where this is enough
probably not
first to check and then go back here
yeah it's actually difficult to get the
pants moving
hmm 90 46 is also bit of a problem
now that did I didn't play well at all
hmm Wow
you
ninety-eight this rook c5
don't don't have anything here that I
can do really about all this
it's odd king of 796 also an issue
six-ten maybe
time
you
you can also play basically any
improving move and not quite sure what
I'm doing then
like f3 yourself is not clear
how I can improve my position
he runs in to check but doesn't doesn't
do much
you
it's remarkable my position
is really passive
you
now he blundered the piece
yeah was a bit lucky that was a bit
lucky he's asking for rematch and why
not
so I'm not going to look at the game at
the moment
okay I've got a good choice between C 3
and C form as he forester the way
usually to Amarok see behind and is's
my favorite opening setup
I really hope that one day when I quit
quit classical time control chess this
is probably not too far away but when
that day comes I will probably retire
without ever having lost the game in the
maroc C bind with white
yeah I'm sitting on c-44 and always
wonder what blacks going to do about it
sitting there with 4 minor pieces and no
space
and I'm just going to play all the pilot
rules and like a suffering this is how
it usually is
not sure here right can you take with
the night such may be a technical
possibility SB 2 is hanging
I should have thought about this for a
moment at least
okay now I can just cover b2
not sure maybe 95
would be a bit odd but
sometimes odd things do work
not so often usually moves that look bad
are bad but sometimes there there are
exceptions
yeah now a six I don't know what is
going to do that B five will never be
possible just never I mean now okay yet
now he can play b5 but just not a good
move I mean I'm going to play B 392 to
before and at the end c6 is going to be
pretty a big problem
I also threatened rook c8 so he's taking
first giving me the C file and yeah this
is again one of those more or less
autopilot games what about B for Luke's
is six oh it's already pretty strong
it's always a tough call because you
have so many strong possibilities but
let's do it like that there's a big hole
on c6 I can also play a knight c2 night
c2 d 46
this is this actually even more tempting
I wonder what he's thinking about I mean
he had to do this I'm going with 90 46
this is even two more think more
problematic for black knight on c6 you
usually cannot stand
you
yeah now what
six comes
you
cannot prevent them
and the night coming to the six is not
going to win the game immediately but
it's pretty awful I'm pretty awful
what's going on here you f4 is going to
go night chief for
mmm Wow I can't even take then in
Playworks e7
already looks pretty pretty awful okay
it's tough because like everything is
very strong
very strong
yeah yeah okay let's do it
tough to say because yeah such a such a
spoiled for choice situation
you
yeah I'm not going to succeed in the
second secondary goal of increment chess
to have more time at the end that you
started with it looked good for 20 moves
but that won't work
you
okay now um I can just take it seven
would be the first thing that comes to
mind I don't think
find something substantially better
yeah I just wondered about this sir what
happens after Quincy aide
because rook does not have that many
squares actually hmm yeah there's
something that I should have thought
about a little bit more you can always
go to a seven definitely okay now how do
we play this I can play Quincy too and
just trying to trade Queen trade is this
of course pretty pretty good
yeah I guess
yeah I don't know if I really
the most out of it
it looked even better than this and the
position in this position might be
winning but
looked like a position where you are
close to having him resign and that's
not going to go to happen here very
likely
now I can go h3 and
and of
okay if he goes to H voice actually
threatening maid and the rookies
attacked this is something that I
definitely should pay attention to pay
attention to he also has bishop takes
and f4 is hanging it's also important
importantly I should not but wait wait
wait h3 Queen h4 this is not a checkmate
threat this is not a checkmate threat if
I move the rook
my take on on default on f4 though
yeah okay so what am I going to play
maybe I just move the knight back
something like that
threatened um maybe rook c7 next he
still has a dead piece there on d8
and it's not like the Queen has many
moves yeah it's really not the case
really
seven sorry Queen c7 I mean
also take on g7
dangerous
the simplest move would be would be just
to play e5
it takes takes you can take it before
then then
something like e six is going to be
winces seven what happens then Knight f7
he has to play
this is really strangely enough not
winning immediately
I can also flick in age three in this
position this is sir
an interesting point I think I would do
that
No
you
release really amazed that there is no
fled out
win apparent
least I don't see it
if I go each five now takes takes bishop
takes now that is actually covered so
then this is a strong move just play e5
yeah if I was covered the rook in seven
and the night is covering it
it's got no check F for Bishop F two
traps the Queen this is actually now
almost possible anyway is got F for
though um
okay now is six I guess
what's the deal we six
you
yeah here I can take on g7 and play
Bishop deform
okay and this is at least enough I'm not
looking for something fancier
can you move the king said to move
I probably will do that because the
other moves are completely lost no okay
you
three funnier the Queen has no square
also there should be five wins the Queen
and he's got no square ik he's got F
form
mm okay yeah the me Roxy I'm one of my
where's my favorite opening to play it's
just so awful for black you have to be
extremely extremely patient and like any
misstep um yeah
I mean it's not funny anyway and if you
make even the slightest mistake in the
defense your position completely sucks
okay you we tell 80 force my opponent
okay
often six is the start for a Dutch
defense not this time
like it's actually going for a double
fianchetto
Oh interesting Quincy aide
yeah I'm always going to do that I think
that trading off this fianchettoed
Bishop is a at least a small
accomplishment and now e52
get more space I guess b5 it's not the
only movement
you
threatening quindi fire it's not exactly
difficult to see but you never know now
sometimes there are discovered attacks
like a knight takes e5 but it does not
seem to be the case in this position I
can threaten that though now threatening
95 and I'm also preparing an item of
maybe 22
95 Bishop g2 and then the knight
discovers check is the threat it's easy
easy to stop but why stop it with this
one now I've got 95
ninety-five
why does he allow that maybe he can take
on g5 Bishop takes e4 and claim that
this position is okay
maybe
maybe
fight takes bishop before
and that could be okay right so I'm
going for them for the simple approach
which will
oddly give white at least a slight
advantage
you
so I'm going to go for f5 just
get this huge space advantage
established
now I think I can go h4 immediately as
after the capture I have rook h1 and he
cannot take twin takes wins immediately
Wow okay interesting I would tell now
that I don't quite know you cannot take
on g3 Queen g3 King Educare seven as
made so that's not good
I mean maybe he's not losing
straightaway if after rook takes h4 next
but it looks pretty bad and unnecessary
really
I'm missing here
nothing
made yeah I could have gone king of
seven but rook age seven is surely going
to be devastating as well
so let's see
similar position type now with colors
reversed yeah the BOGO or the Rico's in
let's play the recursion I'm not s
versed in it yet
because I'd done a fair amount of work
on the opening for the news o recording
course on chesil but still there are
still moments when I don't quite
remember stuff do you go to a six I
don't know
Oh B seven
you
I think I made a mistake yeah with
six square maybe
and untimely night age five okay I need
to think about for this for a moment
there's also Queen a four here so bring
back
check we nee form
you
and you just take such hmm okay
so he went form
really
kind of a keep it simple approach just
trying to play on the C file even though
this does not feel so threatening win
ce7 I can just take and play Bishop d6
no I don't think this is much of a
problem
no Luke see AIDS
you
Queen d6 is also reasonable
you
you
Yahoo p8 is kind of normal I just I just
wondered about what I'm doing next time
so what is his idea he can play Knight
f3 to e5 maybe that
happen
yeah probably the easiest that I can do
is this one
several and to prepare
Roxy ade
okay now go 97
Lucas going back I guess
now
I could just take it on a five and then
play rook c8
yes rooks is seven then it doesn't lead
to anything but
come let's do it
see eight
so we're just going to trade everything
off and play this ending yeah I wonder
if I'm still suffering in this ending or
if it is okay I could still be suffering
a little bit because of the space
God sees he will play eform pretty soon
King comes to deform
hm did this.first
and denied a bit more active
you know I have the check which doesn't
do much
you
[Music]
you
mmm yeah it's very time-consuming but
the night on c4 is good how is he doing
how is he handling the the pawns on the
Queen so I was odd
play before I guess
night c-44 night be too
yeah
going to play it on
you
just stopping you for for the
not doing anything else with the move
now do I have something No
that's a strange square for the vision
my night is kind of dominating the
bishop here it's a rare sight
it's got no bishop move it's really
really funky a kickin d4 I'm going to
going back
you
King bee three night at five
you
I have no clue what what the King and
pawn ending is like no idea
you probably also has no idea what this
is
you
yeah this is not very comfortable
you
got nuclear-related how to fenders
is not really in good shape
you
well that's surprising
you
I see the idea but I don't think that
he's
[Music]
making much headway because now the the
Queen side is going to be completely
closed
I can probably just sit
I could actually run to g7
you
okay and chief
I guess
cannon we would have a draw
okay
looks like a coup
draw
[Music]
anyway right I can do this
you
yeah it's just it's just completely
drawn okay where is that thing
I declined strong what no I think you
just made a Mis click there ok and I
have to watch the clock a little bit
okay just one more game I can do one
more game
then I have to do something let's go
didn't manage much in post game analysis
to do that a bit more but it was a bit
of
the session was a bit problematic
timewise but I wanted to get it in and
not
have an on an on video game wanted to
really make a video today came
you
funny that he allows this move with the
temper wanted to play this anyway
okay now Jim
come on let's just clarify the situation
what is playing basic liquor without any
ambition just
to trade stuff
and it's not so easy to for black
something
one idea to unbalance things a little
bit is b5 but he is fairly well
positioned for this idea
so probably have to do something else
okay so I'm taking this I just I'd want
a bit of an imbalance in this position
so that is not completely symmetrical
and you can trade everything for a draw
some
not too bad in that regard so
to trade Queens and then I'm going to
double against the C pawn and then try
this is a bit helpful actually
and then trying to play with b5 or d5
yeah this is possible this is possible
but if I play d5 now takes he doesn't
want to take
can take v6 and a success immediately
also hanging
that's a bit of a bit of a bummer some
after me cover this for the moment
why are you playing well all of a sudden
playing the hole
[Music]
obviously always the passive move and
then he plays an active move of a son
well and probably not a bad one so what
now
what now yeah I probably have to take
in 94 I guess was the idea
and now what
yeah I guess I go to f6
it will take g6 I guess No
okay I mean my [ __ ] structure is not
good yeah but I'm still surprised that
he wants to play this ending a porn down
you
let's cover this for the moment and then
see if I can make any headway
okay
you
'if I've robbed c5
yeah the the resulting Rukh ending is
probably a draw but
you
anyways this one stupid wants to get the
room to be five
you know yeah you can probably not
winders
King of three is a good month preparing
would be five
now unfortunately
you
yo now you can just not witness
you
I actually have to watch out a little
bit
I'm not getting into some trouble
you
now I'm going to offer him a draw here
this I think film
yeah I mean he can continue there's no
reason for him let's say to make a draw
um but
objectively speaking a draw wasn't
um
was quite quite reasonable in this
position
I know what to do here
I had a similar endgame while ago
left to be a little bit on the lookout
six look f1
you
can you have six again we'll get one
you
you know this is a draw you can
cannot do much either side cannot do
much I had almost the same kind of
position about one and a half years ago
early 2018 in San Sebastian open and
this was also drawn okay guys I have to
run so I hope you enjoyed the tea
session here and I will probably do
something else early next week something
else then blitz getting a new book with
a sophisticated chess problems puzzle
said same on Tuesday and I will
definitely use that book form
you had to explore some new positions
okay thanks a lot for watching bye bye